[Music]
to all citizens of the Dominion
on this eve of my last birthday as your
queen let us have one last festivity
together first party
Vampire Academy is about the friendship
between two young women Rose and Alyssa
as they enter The Adult World they
realize the differences between them in
class might be the thing that either
tears them apart or makes them change
the world together have you ever met a
royal maroy in a high position of Power
with a dampier best friend in this
Dominion there are three distinct
classes the maroy a benevolent mortal
vampire the Don Pierre are raised to
serve the moroy as Guardians they
protect them against the stragoy
immortal bloodthirsty vampires
Rose Hathaway is a dampier she wants to
be the best Guardian yet she questions
why am I doing this I want to protect my
best friend and I want a life to call my
own Melissa dragomir is a royal maroy
vampire she starts off the story really
naive her life kind of gets flipped
upside down put the next Air to the
thrill I name that's Alyssa ragamir it's
all very juicy and very dramatic I like
young love I like love triangles I like
the star-crossed lovers there's Alyssa a
Christian he's a royal maroy
unfortunately he is an outcast
I heard you spent a lot of time here
books don't gossip about me they sort of
have this spark there's a real love
there and a real genuine connection we
shouldn't do this
absolutely not I like the love that was
not meant to be I like the love that
tears us apart and Rose and Dimitri
embody all of that Dimitri is an expert
Guardian the chemistry is real you need
this white rose I know you're hurting
and I'd do anything to make it stop
one of the great things about this show
is that we have all these amazing fights
these don't team created something
beautiful it's like a dance you see a
lot of precision and skill they're
everything I think everyone wants to see
when you're fighting vampires it's
pretty cool getting to do all the
training and the fighting and it's just
nice to see black girls kicking ass and
being brave and being beautiful and I
live for that I live for that we deserve
a better future moroy and Don Pierre
alike Vampire Academy has something very
profound to say about equality gotten
across in a fun and entertaining way
Vampire Academy has love and romance
it's got royal yumminess it tells
stories of loss and grief but it is also
the origin story of a revolution this is
the way the world is then maybe it's the
world that needs to change and what a
thrill to be able to tell that kind of
story with two young women at the center
we are all a part of this Dominion
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hello my name is Christine riccio and
I'm Natasha polis and we're your hosts
for today's peacock Vampire Academy
virtual Premiere event we are super
excited to share all the fun things we
have planned for today Natasha and I are
both huge readers we've been Vampire
Academy fans forever my early book talks
are just me rambling about Rose Hathaway
and pronouncing everything in the books
wrong did anyone else say to hamper no
but that's actually how we first became
besties this is a series we both hold
near and dear to our hearts we are
thrilled to kick off and celebrate the
new peacock original Vampire Academy
with you guys we have so much planned
for today from fun Vampire Academy
themed games with the cash and
showrunners for never before seen
footage but before we start I think you
guys all want to see the cash we should
bring out the cast right let's meet the
cats
first up we have CeCe Stringer as Rose
Hathaway
[Applause]
Daniela Nieves is listener
[Applause]
here and more is Dimitri felikov
[Music]
Andre day Kim as Christian ozera
Jay August Richard as Victor dashcov
Anita joy uwaje as Tatiana vocal
Mia McKenna Bruce as Mia Carr yeah
thank you
as Meredith Beckham
Janetta Kaiser as Sonya Carr
foreign
ER as Mason Ashford
[Applause]
we are so excited to have you all here
are you guys all feeling good
are y'all excited at home
it's so exciting that we're all here
right now I kind of really want to take
a selfie I think we should do a selfie
yes should we do a selfie yes I have my
phone right here let's do it okay let's
do this
if we must come on
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get this show started
alrighty y'all it's time to put your
acting skills to the test and see how
well you know the Vampire Academy
characters we know you know your own
roles but it's time to see how well you
know each other's we're going to play a
game of Charades it's time for the
vampire act Academy oh it'll be assigned
a Vampire Academy character at random
you need to act out the role without
words or sounds for the rest of the cast
and everyone will guess May the best
lesbian
so our first choice is going to be Anita
Joy but before
make sure that you're guessing in the
comments yes yes we're gonna go over
here we gotta watch this this is gonna
be something
don't do that thing let's go
all right how do I hold on to it
get 67 okay
yep Ready Go Set Go
thank you
[Applause]
well done thank you baby
[Applause]
come on
oh this is hard
okay you ready you ready you ready
Mason yep boom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you
okay Mia it's your turn why don't you
take the stage come on okay
all right we ready yeah
go
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right ready yep
Jay
oh
wow
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's cool
okay okay
here we go okay
nice to meet you thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
because we've hit the point where you
can't just do punches every time you
said dampier so I'm running out of stuff
we could do yeah wow that's what I
that's what I actually do guys wow
all right back
[Music]
thank you
okay
here we go all right ready yeah
oh ready yeah yeah let's go are you sure
that yeah okay Tatiana
yes yes
[Applause]
I barely got to strut
[Music]
[Applause]
come on now
[Applause]
thank you
her mouth no God
stop stop
losing seconds here come on oh okay
okay pretend pretend there's a chair
yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
I know I don't know why I did that yeah
oh yeah
whoa whoa let's go girl
all right
you got another big one
okay
[Applause]
sorry Karen yeah
yeah oh that big talk now I'm so scared
because there's a couple I have no idea
what to do
Dimitri Mia here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
really good
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah
nice work y'all you're too good you guys
are amazing you guys are such good
actors
so good you guys know each other so well
you're too good for the inside jokes
happening that we were on the app so we
didn't get any of them right on the
inside once they've watched this year
I was guessing like Gondola Jesus I we
didn't know
the fun is just getting started up in
here we want you all at home to
celebrate the premiere along with us our
friends at peacock have created an
Instagram lens filter so you too can
walk the blood red carpet you can find
the filter in your Instagram effects
Library by searching peacocktv in the
effects search engine the filter lets
you strut your stuff on the virtual red
carpet and when you make eye contact
with the lens your eyes will glow like
the more eyes do in the show don't
forget to post it on your story tag at
peacocktv and hashtag Vampire Academy we
cannot wait to see all of your vampire
looks Yes
actually we have some special guests we
want to introduce so we're going to make
some room for them
I'm so excited to reveal that joining us
for this segment are the amazing
showrunners of Vampire Academy Julie
pleck and Marguerite McIntyre
nice thank you
guys this next segment was made for
Vampire Academy stands we invited fans
of the series to Showcase their art on
the show today and you can already see a
ton of their gorgeous work here on the
stage walls we'll show our cast a zoomed
in image of a piece of fan art and
on the monitor it will slowly zoom out
to reveal the full picture we want you
to play along with us so shout out your
guesses of what that art may be before
we get to the big reveal the first fan
art piece we have is from at Miss escara
underscore two can you all guess who's
in the picture
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right our next fan art piece is by
at hiccupt underscore Studio who do you
think is featured in this right okay
what episode could be this is okay
[Applause]
okay and finally our last talented
artist is at Hathaway roses who do you
think she Drew
yeah I would say rose
[Music]
[Applause]
we reposted those ones I love I love
that one
it's so good oh my gosh can you guys all
agree that Vampire Academy fans are so
freaking talented
[Applause]
so for this next segment we asked
peacock's Instagram fans to slide into
our DMS to ask the questions they're
dying to know about the show everyone
will answer a damned fan question that
was sent to us via Instagram for those
of you watching keep a weather eye out
you might see yours first up is Mia
at the headquarters asks what's the
funniest story that happened on set
oh okay
um funny stories there's hundreds of
funny stories I think I spent the whole
time laughing um one would be we were
doing a scene myself Janetta and Jay and
we call well people called us the
Tresemme no The Three Amigos yeah and
then as we were about to they're like
rolling they're about to call Action and
Jay just goes translations which means
three mils I think it's five so me and
Jeanette just stopped dying and then
obviously having to film a scene
um every time they're about to say
action hearing Tres Leches it was the
only phrase I knew in Spanish with three
in it so
right that made the cut of the show wait
I'm sorry it wasn't the name of the
hotel yeah
yes yes exactly oh you're right yeah
I could have gone for that one yeah
yes exactly yeah he was going for three
kids
I like it to Joy
oh that's a very good question
um this has to just be one
um I would say all of them were amazing
to film but my favorites would be
probably nine and ten I
think oh yeah very juicy yeah
and then uh for re at silda under
J ask
s how similar are you to your character
I don't know if I like that reaction
I'm quite quite similar I think the the
whole um
sarcasm and being a bit more brutally
honest than everybody would care for me
to be
um it's something I have a habit of
doing
in the best way right
um but no I think yeah and she's and
she's secretly really sensitive our next
question is for Joan Nava and it's from
Advent Academy Army and they ask if you
could be a vampire from Vampire Academy
which would you be oh that's a really
hard question
[Laughter]
I'd be Sonia carp
and wear some pretty dresses
she was pretty she just got some
gorgeous dresses yeah the next question
is for Jay August this is from Vampire
Academy bound they ask what's the emoji
describes your character
nobody get naughty right
one one would be a spoiler so I can't
say that so can I choose three yeah okay
yeah so so it would be uh the sunshine
Emoji the wide-eyed Emoji guy and then
another Sunshine Emoji because when
Victor lowers his eyes they turn golden
our next question is for Drew it's from
at t y r c n d y i ask what's your
favorite BTS moment
not the band
[Laughter]
um
I think we all went to Barcelona on the
same weekend and I think we all met up
and we had just the best time and we
were filming a bunch and it was just
very hectic and working and working and
working and we saw Barcelona all
together and it was really special
so the next question is for Julie at
pink underscore room underscore reads
asks what do you hope nude old fans take
away from the show
oh gosh I mean I hope new fans are like
this is awesome
um but I think old fans of the books
will I hope really um
might take a minute but hopefully you'll
appreciate the way that Marguerite and I
took sort of everything that we loved
about the entirety of the book series
and and worked it in to our take in our
adaptation of the television series
we're huge fans of the material and so
we wanted to make sure all those great
moments found their way into the
episodes eventually so sometimes it's
not like where you think it's going to
be but it's probably in there if it's a
moment that you loved so generally
speaking I hope everybody loves
everything
and Julia Marguerite I know you guys
have known each other for like 20 plus
years how has that like impacted your
collaboration the trust the like your
creative process all of that
well I mean I'm her biggest fan and have
been you know for a long time like
pre-share of Forbes days but dating all
the way back to a show we did together
called Kyle XY I think she's one of the
most magnificently talented people on
this planet uh and certainly certainly
in every thing that she does but also uh
on the page as a writer so if margarit
says she likes something I'm like okay
but my favorite thing besides every
ditto 100 back to you I mean it's Julie
Fleck we all know how brilliant she is
but one of my favorite things with you
is when we get on a roll when we're
breaking a story and we're like I don't
know what's the thing the thing we both
will suddenly say the same Rando word
out of the blue that nobody will have
thought of yet we're like
or whatever
literally like our brains are starting
to melt when they get there and they get
there and it makes me laugh so hard
because there's just this weak come at
it from this different process and we
land in the same place and it's so
thrilling and so enjoyable but also if
we were shooting in Europe in Spain and
we shared a flat we're a roommate we
were roommates and we um we'd wrap it
like four in the morning and we'd come
home and we'd drink beer and eat
Laughing Cow Cheese and do our book
rerun do all of our little homework at
the end of the day I know can you see
somebody breaks an ankle or something
you have to shift some scenes around and
you know
I'm like week one somebody breaks
but it was fun it was really really fun
[Laughter]
our next question is for you Marguerite
and it's from at loric book dragon and
they ask which episode you can't wait
for people to see oh
I heard you guys it's really really hard
this is hard because
one of the things I'm the most proud of
is that every episode that you watch the
next episode feels like it gets deeper
and better and more exciting because we
know the characters more and we're more
excited by the adventure so I feel like
if if I said it was two it would be
three and if I said it was three would
be four and all the way through so I
just feel like I'm this is a Cheesy
answer but I'm kind of excited for them
to see the entirety of the series I'm so
excited the cast has finally seen most
of it and I'm like now you know what
you're in right and they're like oh my
God yeah so I think that's my answer I
just want people to like love the whole
thing
yeah enjoy it as a whole and for CeCe at
Vampire Academy bound ask how many tick
tocks or reels are in the drafts right
now from Spain oh my God
okay no no actually let me think about
this
okay I'm gonna say like eight
um however I have a list of about a
hundred ideas that I had thought of and
that I've been slowly executing so you
will see some crazy some crazy stuff I
just I literally have this image of you
I thought based on your your Instagram
like I'm like CC just sits at home at
night and like the middle of the night
she can't sleep she's up and she's just
like working the gram working the gram
yeah you're good at it you're right
you're right I love that stuff and like
it's a really good way to connect with
the fans as well like yeah all the fan
art that we see around us they they've
already sent us and they've tagged us
and we get to see it and talk to them so
it's really really cool I love Instagram
social media is an amazing tool our next
question is for Andre at celo hinojosa
asks what did they take from the set
what do they take from the
setup
world of experience
yourself what is this assumption that
I'd be the one
[Music]
um
it's okay listen
um we all got our chair backs which I
think was really nice we got to take and
obviously I took away all the great
memories and friendships
[Laughter]
what I would like to take from the set
there you go that's good don't keep this
unlock by the way uh maybe because Chris
Christian's lighter I think yeah so if
that goes missing
some props but we're not allowed to talk
about it yet because it's spoilers I'm
sure we will hear more about the props
stolen from set after the show
um
account asks what has been your favorite
part about joining the fandom and having
a strong fan base oh well
um firstly the amazing reception
um which has been amazing but also the
um the passion for something that's so
like shared and loved by these people
and we got to win we're part of that
process now and hopefully there'll be a
bond that's even stronger when the show
comes out and we can talk about it a
little bit more
um but yeah I'm just hoping that they
can be as excited as we are when we made
it yeah yeah just quite it's still I
feel um very welcome and there's a bit
of a relative Outsider I kind of like
the idea of having a little family with
these guys and hopefully the funds we
love you
our next question is for Daniella at Don
pierwomen ask what was your favorite
costume on the show oh see you had some
good costumes yeah Sonia Grande did an
amazing job and she really I mean all
the outfits that she picked for Lisa
were incredible
um but there was this one like Valentino
dress like jacket sweater thing that was
so cute and she had these little white
heels and I felt like Jackie was so
sweet and then
um in like nine and or ten I think it's
ten I wear this beautiful gown and I
have these like sleeves these white like
princesses and a big hoop skirt and uh
Tiara so that one was also like that
stunning stunning unfortunately Julie
and Marguerite have to leave us but
before they go can y'all explain to the
live stream what is your goya's yes
as a matter of fact we can
some qualities of Mr [ __ ] to spoil
backstabbing they don't die they don't
die straight away feral feral driven by
the
unrelenting need to feed
Immortal very difficult to kill
violent violent mean the nasty vampire
not the hot brooding no you know 12-pack
AB vampires not not big not big fans of
the of the moroy either they're good
they're kind of an enemies they're
better yeah yeah they've lost their
souls they have soulless soulless good
ones bloodthirsty uh so this definition
is very important for the next game but
before we get to that let's just say
goodbye to Julia Margarita thank you we
don't get to play the games today bye
everybody thank you thank you
thank you
oh my gosh it was so cool
the next game we're playing is called
imposter where the cast members need to
figure out who the strugoy is at the
table I'm gonna steal jonetta J August
Andrew Mia Rianne and Anita joy for this
game if you could all move over to the
table and take a seat you'll see six
unmarked goblets and at random everyone
take one to drink from
one of these six goblets contains nasty
tasting blood everyone's going to take a
sip of their liquid and our cast has to
try to figure out who is the stragoi AKA
who has the blood if you're the Superboy
you want to try your best to keep a
straight face and lie your way through
the game so you don't get caught if you
had the good drink you want to find out
who got the bad one the one with the
blood at the end everyone will vote to
apprehend the Rogues to [ __ ] the strugoy
wins if they don't get caught but
everyone else wins if they do it's kind
of like Mafia but with a Twist is
everyone ready
yeah take a drink I'm scared
you made me feel so on edge immediately
Cheers Cheers
Bottoms Up
I already know who it is
Hulker faces are on oh we have enough
Mia come on you're just like a classic
she's gonna laugh so
oh if she's failing I don't know I don't
know
like Maria's playing it real cool yeah
no one's winning at her
I don't I need a joy just immediately
started pointing
she's trying to throw everyone off okay
should we spit all right everyone spit
it out okay
that was under the bus I was trying to
say Anita Joy threw everybody under the
bus but I think it was JoJo dancer
I think I think if we if we roll the
tape back
immediately
he's tasted it from the first time
okay
majority vote I vote for Joe Joe I don't
know I don't vote for Jojo I'm on this
side I'm gonna vote for Jojo oh wow
oh wait three buses three yeah I need a
majority well should we but if the three
of them vote for one person then it's a
tie
yeah I was I was pictures again wait it
was me yeah but I'm not off you yet oh
wow
he was pulling a bit with your face yeah
yeah she was yeah that's true
yeah I vote for Mia all right I'll just
I'll just make it interesting okay we
all voted for me absolutely what do you
mean okay guys
reveal yourself
reveal yourself
oh
yeah
oh my God that was good not one vote
good job good job good job
all right all right we're having so much
fun all right can I get you all over
here to this area please thank you all
so much for playing with us if you guys
want to leave a comment down below and
let us know how excited you are for this
season of Vampire Academy but up next
it's time to reveal a big surprise heck
yeah we have an exclusive clip of the
cast giving a set tour and you were the
first ones in the world to get to see it
we're so excited to share this exclusive
clip with you get ready for some vampire
Shenanigans without further Ado what we
have all been waiting for here is the
never before seen clip from Vampire
Academy
[Applause]
and we're rolling I'm about to tell you
where the real action starts let's talk
let's do it I can't tell you exactly
what you're gonna see because you will
see everything
take one action
hello I'm CeCe Stringer and I play
rosemary Hathaway on Vampire Academy and
here we are in beautiful Elite Spain
we're in a Spanish Monastery and we have
this beautiful castle and that serves as
our Academy
all of our sets have been practical and
so as actors we get to just sort of jump
into this and immerse ourselves in the
physicality of it all
we are currently in the monastery but
the set designers came in and built this
maroy Dawn hallway to the rich and upper
class tell them to go easy on the starch
I have a feeling that someone's in this
room someone who might like to see me
hey what's up guys
this is my room I think it's so colorful
to really contrast the the lifeless
barracks yeah that's where I sleep
swarming it with the rest of us now
tell us about the unicorns Christian has
a lovely line where he says listen you
really are a unicorn so naturally I have
17 unicorns in my bedroom
[Music]
I don't need a man to save me neither do
I it's Andre here I play Christian
rosera this is my room
there's a bunch of books Christian's a
big reader it's old maroy really is kind
of beautiful
Spain is cool man when we first got here
it was a monastery and some fields and a
Vineyard and now if you check out the
set it's completely transformed yeah
it's just it's incredible it's so
magical we see Mia a lot in Victor's
house that's our family home it's very
bougie very cool where else do I spend
time a little bit in the guardian
training barracks
this is where Sonia spends all of her
time the set at night it's so romantic
all of the candles are lit this is her
place
we are at Elite Castle this is where we
shoot a lot of our Royal Court scenes we
have an obligation to everyone not just
the muroy obviously the costumes are
Super Fly check this thing out the
minute I put this outfit on and started
walking around these locations I knew
exactly who the character was behind me
Saint Vladimir's Academy it's just a
pretty romantic and special environment
you know what you've done
where we filmed some really incredible
scenes I'd sooner die than see your
family's bloodline on the throne perhaps
the Saints will grant you your wish
she's got a very great wardrobe personal
favorite is probably the one I've got
now because this is the First dress that
I wore in the show which was just so
cool
I need a favor can you pass this out a
note for me no way we're currently in
the courtyard for some vladimirs but by
far one of my favorite places to be was
the dampier bar the whole thing was
designed for us and it's also where we
keep our memorials for all of the Fallen
dampers which I think it's key in the
show to remember that it is life or
death for these guys you're kind of a
guardian nerd aren't you I'm Kira Moore
I've been Dimitri bellikov I'm about to
tell you where the real action starts
fight them this is some cool lights
and cool fights
I'm impressed who it is I play Mason
Ashford he's um better than Dimitri he
has this undying love for Rose I'm more
comfortable on top don't I know it easy
it's my girl
it's not real there is no special
effects everything you see has been
performed which is a credit to the
amazing stuff team we have here that's
just a little bit of what's going on in
the show this whole experience is once
in a lifetime we have all fell in love
with these characters yeah we've built a
little family here man we've got a
little family we're gonna use like
nothing I need you to stop I'm gonna use
all of it I need you to stop
unfortunately that's the end of our show
thank you so much for joining us today
we had a blast playing around with the
cast and show Runners of Vampire Academy
don't forget to watch Vampire Academy
streaming now on peacock thank you so
much
oh
my God
foreign